the end of our pockets what we do is
listen called unhelpful advice and we
have people ask us questions and then
you can give it advice or ones that
aren't healthy and this be sponsored by
my tell like it is George is that what
it is like it is tore and said Dean cook
table ticking forward yeah and I'm
telling you every eight sleepers okay
listen to me okay you guys came out in
droves in San Jose come out for my boy
right here Dane Cook what dates are
coming up everything's on the website I
got I get dates the rest of the year
literally the rest of the year I'm doing
every weekend for the rest of the year
yeah okay so go to that everyone
hopefully and then I have a movie lined
up with dr. ken cook brought to you by
so it is tow it like it is tour there we
go uh hey guys when I was in high school
my dad took a job in Doha Qatar we lived
in Boston for a four year contract with
the US government my daddy and I were
very close and I had a hard time
processing this three years into the
contract my parents tell me that my
sisters were getting a divorce because
he had an affair with some Australian
woman there during the divorce it was
revealed to me that he spent the money
my parents had saved for my college fund
it's a real friend a few girlfriends
alcohol addiction and building her a new
hair salon naturally I was infuriated we
haven't had a good relationship sense
cut to my mid-20s now my dad has been
diagnosed with diabetes he seems to
think this new diagnosis is a path for
us to have a good relationship now I'm a
nurse and he's expecting me to guide him
through this disease am I still right to
be upset and distance myself or should I
forgive him and help out Bobby it's all
lost on Bobby so let me give you a quick
synopsis when he's in high school okay
he's there for four years spends the
kids college tuition on a girlfriend
that he met there uh-huh to open up a
hair salon yeah
dad now gets diabetes and it's like
thinks it's a free pass to be forgiven
for blowing a woman he met in the Middle
East you know it's not a free pass but
it is your dad right what what do you
mean so forgive I would you know what I
would do I'd say you know what Dad I
want to help but I want a piece of the
hair salon
ten percent bump each month right Oh
does he still has the hair salon yeah
and the woman that he gave the hair
salon to is apparently like an alcoholic
right yeah that's a tough one yes dad
yeah yeah well you wouldn't what do you
think What's Wrong baby
I wouldn't blindly forgive we would have
a discussion no there'd be consequences
like what and I'd be reimbursed in one
way or another because that is my call
it as my future that you've forsaken for
an alcoholic lady who wanted to open a
[ __ ] salon like I would judge I would
be really concerned about where his
judgment is there's a whole nother side
of that spectrum which is there's an
alcoholic woman who has a hair so here's
another thing though I forgive him after
he lost the foot but the way I would
happen come on you gonna do the diabetes
get to that point yeah I'd be like you
know what it but he if he's like let's
say he's on the border of type 2
diabetes yeah and he could still alter
his lifestyle to be in better health if
that was an option for him I wouldn't
forgive him if he was if he already had
a gangrenous foot and then he had like a
below-the-knee amputation I'd be like
you know what now's the time oh my god
at gage where his wound has wound care
because how do you follow my hypothesis
whenever something like that happens now
it's like I always think to myself and
it may be this is like delusional
thinking
I always think oh that's just the will
not God's will but it's just the way
it's supposed to be and I'll go this way
like if I was a kid yeah oh my dad would
laughter he's in the Middle East took
all my money he's opened up a salon oh
that's [ __ ]
I guess he's out
gonna do this now because I have to
survive but I always feel like this is
the what I'm supposed to be doing
because the in me the other thing
happened do you think that that one oh
the journey of this damn whole thing is
just for finding out how to let go of
hurt in fear in pain and so by by
perpetuating this this person whether if
they don't help their dad there they are
just perpetuating the pain it could stop
the pain by saying you know dad I love
you you're not a perfect person I have
some issues with you I'm gonna help you
right now and then you're gonna help me
out with that's it right there - [ __ ]
dr. Drew this is the guy dr. Drew was
here what last week that's what I say
every morning when I wake up this is the
guy you know it's it's it's you know
that's you know the woman in the middle
east alcoholics like yes like that
answer
[Music]